final present from the three minute
thesis competition is dairy tanta vijaya
and her title for the event is read the
web milk drinkers are turning to powder
what can this mean we as humans know
that humans don't become powder just for
chicken meal so this headline can only
mean that the same registers are simply
switching to powdered milk imagine now a
computer that can read and understand
this headline the way we wouldn't it be
awesome unfortunately most computers can
read or understand the way humans do
mostly lives in the universe of keywords
in fact as one New York writer observes
Google doesn't understand that the
answer to the simple question can an
Eliot around 100 meter hurdles is no
alligators cannot run hurdles instead
google returns pages from florida gators
track and field the reason why one of
the reason why this question what this
headline is difficult is because there
is quite common sense something that
comes naturally to pass but for
computers is difficult at the read the
web group you are developing a computer
system we call now for never any
language learner that learns to extract
tracks common sense or more about the
word the world from web document now can
learn and these categories relations
that is are involved for example now has
learned that the word disney is an
entity of category company whose CEO is
either now can now learn on its own now
and let the peace they represent very
well it does not yet learned about works
so currently it thinks that Snow White
and Mulan are actors in Disney movies
because now doesn't know that the verbs
representing acting in movies such as to
act or to perform requires the entities
to be at least enemy not animated
so my thesis is in enabling nail to
learn this works on its own the kind of
relations that the first evoke and the
kinds of entities that can get involved
when the research is complete now we'll
be able to read and understand even more
sentences and can potentially help many
people in many different fields criminal
investigators for instance can rely on
now to comb through thousands of reports
and rely on ellcrys and summaries of
parties involved in with the
relationships between the parties
involved in a crime now can read and
understand rumors gossips chatters about
companies that can potentially inform
trading decisions and of course now can
conclude much to the relief work will
drinkers everywhere then they will still
be pretty much alive even after turning
powder